(bright music)
- Our Howison Lecturer for
this year is Fred Dretske,
one of the leading figures
on the contemporary scene
working on problems in
the areas of epistemology
and philosophy of mind.
Professor Dretske received the BSEE degree
in Electrical Engineering from
Purdue University in 1954.
His graduate studies were conducted
at the University of Minnesota,
where he was rewarded the MA
degree in Philosophy in 1958,
and the PhD in 1960, also in Philosophy
with a minor in Mathematics.
Professor Dretske taught
at the University of
Wisconsin-Madison from 1960 to 1990,
and at Stanford University
from 1990 to 1998.
At the latter institution,
he was the Bella and Eloise
Mabury Knapp Professor of Philosophy.
He now holds the title
of Professor Emeritus
from both Wisconsin and Stanford,
and in addition, since 1999,
Professor Dretske has been
affiliated with Duke University
as a Senior Research Scholar.
Professor Dretske's work is focused on
some of the central issues
in contemporary epistemology
and philosophy of mind,
and his contributions
have had a profound effect
on the contemporary
understanding of these issues.
An animating concern of his has been
to make sense of
knowledge, rational action,
and conscious experience
in naturalistic terms
as phenomena that are possible
in a materialistic world.
Professor Dretske defends
a form of externalism
in both epistemology
and philosophy of mind,
arguing that the contents
of thought and experience
are fixed in part, by the external,
i.e., causal and historical relations
between subject and environment.
For instance, he has proposed
a non-epistemic account
of the content of visual experience
according to which, we see many
things that we do not notice
at the time when we see them.
Similarly, knowledge on
Professor Dretske's account,
is a matter of being
connected to the facts
in the right way,
not having justifications
for one's beliefs.
More recently, Professor
Dretske has defended
a representationalist account
of the character of phenomenal experience,
which holds that content and quality
of our conscious experiences
depend, in part, on our
biological histories.
Conscious experience remains a focus
of Professor Dretske's ongoing research,
including, in particular,
the problem of understanding
how knowledge of one's own
conscious states is possible.
Professor Dretske's many
influential publications include
several books that have
become classics in our field:
Seeing and Knowing from 1969,
Knowledge and the Flow
of Information from 1981,
Explaining Behavior from 1988,
and Naturalizing the Mind from 1995.
A selection of his influential
philosophical essays,
Perception, Knowledge and Belief
was published by Cambridge
University Press in 2000,
and we're also, of course,
delighted to welcome him
to Berkeley today as this
year's Howison Lecturer.
He'll be speaking to us on What We See.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you very much, Jay.
Well, as Jay mentioned,
this has been a topic
that has been with me
for 40 years, off and on,
and I return to the topic now,
not because I've changed my mind,
but because
the view I espoused 40 years ago
requires a much different sort of defense
than it did 40 years ago.
So much has happened in
the last 20 or 30 years
in psychology and cognitive
neuroscience on perception,
that one can hardly
advance anything without
addressing some of the issues
that are raised by that research,
and so, this is what I am doing today, I'm
giving you
what Jay described as a view
of non-epistemic seeing,
but simultaneously trying to
address some of these issues
that arise in cognitive neuroscience.
Now, I've got a subtitle here,
The Texture of Conscious Experience,
because I wanted to clarify
that what I'm interested in here,
is what's going on in your head
at the time you see something,
I'm calling that a conscious experience,
something you can extinguish
just by closing your eyes
and make reoccur by opening your eyes,
it's that, that I wanna talk about.
What I'm interested in is what I'm calling
the texture of that.
I'm looking at an audience,
there are, I don't know how
many people in this room,
at least a hundred, say,
how much of that richness
that's in the world,
how much of that detail,
how much of that texture that's out there
occurs in here, in a conscious way,
when I look out at the world?
That's the issue that I'm concerned with,
and I'm concerned with that issue because
recently, in the last 10 or 20 years,
so many different strands of thought
have started converging on the idea that
our subjective impression
of seeing so much detail
and texture of the world in
brief glances, is an illusion.
There is detail and texture out there,
but it's an illusion to
think that it occurs in here,
and the illusion is fostered
by the easy availability of details
because we can just flick our eyes around
and pick up any information we care to,
and the impression is fostered
that all that detail
that is so easily accessible in the world,
is occurring in the head,
even during brief glances,
and that is an illusion.
Some of you, perhaps,
know of Dan Dennett's,
well-known example of staring at a wall
filled with Marilyn Monroe pictures,
hundreds of pictures, and Dan says that
it's hard to resist the feeling that
you see hundreds of pictures,
just with a brief glance,
but he says, no that's a mistake,
that's an illusion.
There is that out in the
world, it's not in your head.
All that's in your head is the ability
to access that detail by moving your eyes.
So, that's the kind of position
I want to argue against.
I've got just a few pictures of here
of some of the, these are
just examples, you could,
you all know that picture.
Now, just looking at that very
briefly for a few seconds,
you have the impression of enormous detail
and you're aware of that detail.
This is a street in New Delhi.
This is not tonight's sky you'll see
with the undated eye, this is
through the Hubble Telescope,
but just looking up at the night sky.
The impression is that you see hundreds,
perhaps, thousands of stars,
in one brief glance.
Then here's a pine
forest in North Carolina,
and the
subjective impression is
that just in a few seconds
you see many, many trees.
Alright, let me start then, by,
and I'm going to start here
by talking, I'm gonna make some,
and philosopher's love to
do this and I'm gonna do it,
make some distinctions, some
linguistic distinctions
because you can't talk
about visual perception
without at least
at the outset, making it
clear to your listeners,
exactly how you're going
to use these words.
So, I'm going to start by
saying that I'm going to use,
I know psychologists and
certainly, neuropsychologists,
use perception
to mean, roughly speaking,
the pick up of usable information
from the light by the eyes.
Without any preconception
of whether that information
is ever embodied
in a conscious experience.
So that, for example, down here
you have unconscious perception,
perception of an object without
awareness of that object,
in such a thing as blindsight,
I don't know how many of you
are familiar with blindsight.
It's
a case where
damage to the brain, the
person denies seeing anything,
but can be demonstrated to
be picking up information
that he can be, that he uses
in making certain choices,
what are called forced choices.
So, when you ask him questions,
he gets an amazingly number
of those questions right
about the stimulus,
even though denying seeing anything.
Alright, that's blindsight,
and then there's other
discoveries from the last 20, 30 years,
different streams in which
visual information is processed,
dorsal and ventral,
ventral is conscious, dorsal is not,
but I'm going to be
using the verb, to see,
to mean conscious perception.
When you pick up usable information
about your environment with the eyes,
and this information is
given conscious embodiment,
the kind of experience you're
now having of me, I hope.
A conscious experience.
So, when I talk about what you see,
I'm not going to be talking about
jut getting information about something,
but when that information
gives rise to a conscious experience.
Alright then, let's start by talking about
the different things we see.
We talk about seeing objects,
sticks, stones, stars,
people, houses, stop signs,
and when I talk about seeing objects,
I'm going to include, although
they're not really objects,
events, football games,
movements, so you're not
seeing not only my hand,
but the movement of my hand.
I'm going to count those
both as objects for
this purpose.
I'm going to treat as an object
anything that exists or occurs
at a particular place and time.
So, the movement of my hand,
occurs now, in this room.
So, I'll count it as an object.
Alright, that's one thing we see, objects.
We also speak of seeing properties.
Properties of the objects we see,
color of his tie, the size of the house,
position of his pawn,
and I'm going to include
as objects, relations.
We see three things and we see one of them
as between the other two,
or on top of something,
or inside of something.
One thing occurs before another.
See these relations between things.
Alright, properties,
are what philosophers
call abstract objects.
They don't occur to place and time.
They are universals,
nonetheless, we speak of seeing them.
I could see the color of his
tie, the shape of his nose,
the size of his car, and so on.
Alright,
thirdly,
sorry, this is just a illustration of
in the top, we speak of
seeing different objects
and the same properties.
That is, I've got Judy
and Trudy as twins here,
supposing you see Judy and she's,
has an identical twin, Trudy,
this is a case where you
see different objects,
but since they look exactly the same,
you see the same properties,
same shape, same colors.
Everything looks the same,
so that the properties
you're aware of are the same,
nonetheless, you're aware
of different objects.
You see different objects,
see the same properties.
On the bottom, we have
seeing the same object,
but different properties.
You have a white drum,
then you bathe the white
drum in blue light,
so now, what you're aware
of is the same white drum,
but what you're aware of
is not the color white,
but the color blue.
That's the color you actually perceive,
and then, of course, you squash the drum,
and you see a different shape,
and this is the final,
this is the white drum
at a great distance, at that distance,
the white drum looks
like just a black spot,
you can barely see it, you can,
might say to yourself, "What
is that I see over there?"
As you get closer,
you can see, perhaps,
that it's a white drum,
but from that distance, it looks,
the shape is not visible,
it's color is not visible,
nonetheless, you do see the white drum,
if you kept your eye on it and walked up,
you would confirm that
that's what you were seeing
at a great distance.
So, this is, just shows
you the independence
of seeing objects and properties.
Finally, we speak of seeing facts.
Now facts, seeing, the facts we see,
are simply the things that
we come to know by seeing.
I see that his tie is blue,
that her keys are on the table,
that, that, what I see
over there, is a squirrel,
that A and B are different or the same,
that A is moving.
Now, ordinarily, the facts we see,
the things we come to know by seeing,
we come to know them by seeing
by seeing objects and their properties.
I see that his tie is blue,
I see that fact, I come to know that fact
by seeing an object,
his tie, and a property,
the color of his tie,
and then, about magically,
I know that his tie is blue.
How do I know it?
I can see that it's blue.
I see a certain fact by seeing the object
and the property of that object.
Now often, of course, we see facts
that aren't facts about
the objects we see.
I see that I'm almost out of gas,
my gas tank is almost empty.
I see that, not by seeing my gas tank,
or the gasoline in it,
but by seeing the fuel
gauge on the dashboard.
So, sometimes, we see a fact
about an object over here,
by seeing an object
here in its properties,
that as, would tell us
what's going on over there,
carries information about that.
That's what measuring
instruments do for us,
or photographs, or television, newspapers.
I see that there's violence
in the Middle East,
not by witnessing the
violence in the Middle East,
but by reading the newspaper.
All I see is the newspaper and the print,
but I speak of myself as being able to see
that certain thing as so, in that way.
Alright, now, those are the distinctions
I want you to keep in mind,
seeing objects, seeing
properties, and seeing facts,
and now, I'm just going
to list a few dangers,
which over the years,
I've found are dangers
if people don't keep those
three things distinct.
The first danger
is, it's not really a danger,
it's the kind of, only a
danger for philosophers,
but it's, if you're a skeptic,
you're gonna end up as an idealist
if you don't keep
this distinctions in mind,
because this is the way
the argument would go.
Supposing you're a skeptic, you say,
"I cannot be sure, I
don't know for certain
"that what I'm aware of is a real apple.
"After all, I could be dreaming.
"Some Cartesian demon
could be deceiving me.
"I could be hallucinating,
I can't be sure, can't know.
"Therefore, when looking at a real apple,
"I cannot see that
"it is a real apple.
"I can't get knowledge
by seeing the apple.
"Therefore," and here's
where the confusion comes,
"I do not see a real apple.
"What is it that I am aware of then?
"Well, it must be a mental image,
"a sense-datum, something
mental in nature."
Now that's a progression
from skepticism to
a conclusion about what we see
that confuses the facts,
which you can't see,
according to the skeptic,
with the perception of objects,
a fallacy, that is simply a confusion
of seeing two quite different things.
Second danger, mistaking
property blindness
for object blindness.
Now, we all know enough about
the retina to know that
in peripheral vision,
you're blind to the colors of
things in peripheral vision.
They all land on
rods, which have no color sensitivity.
Now, one shouldn't conclude, however,
that because you cannot see the color,
a property of objects in
peripheral vision, or night vision,
that therefore, you cannot
see the colored objects,
in peripheral vision.
It doesn't follow that because
I can't see the blueness
of that object over there,
that I can't see the
blue object over there.
That would be confusing
the properties of it
with the thing that has those properties,
and although, I may not
be able to see the color,
maybe even not the shape
of objects over there
in extreme peripheral
vision, it doesn't follow,
that I don't see those objects,
and finally, and this
is a danger, I think,
with people who do
the kind of experiments
with change blindness
that, perhaps, many of
you are familiar with.
Some people are careful
in describing the results
of these experiments,
but I think some people
tend to be careless,
and so, I just want to
call attention to the fact
that we don't want to mistake ignorance of
or failure to notice or
detect objects and properties,
as a failure to see them.
So, this is the way one
might commit this fallacy.
You say that a subject does
not see, detect, or notice
the difference between
stimulus A and stimulus B,
that is, does not see the
fact that they differ.
Alright, so they're
blind to a certain fact,
the fact that A and B differ.
What do you conclude from that?
That they are blind to
the objects or properties
that make them different?
That's to confuse a fact
with an object or a property.
You should not confuse
the perception of facts,
the fact that A and B differ,
with the perception of
the objects and properties
that make A and B different.
Now, I'm gonna come
back to change blindness
a little later with some examples
because I think it's change blindness or
results like that that
convince many people
that
they see less than they might,
otherwise, suppose they see.
Alright, here's a case
of change blindness.
I'm gonna show you this for a few seconds,
then I'm going to show you
that for a few seconds.
Did you all see the difference
between those two figures?
Now, if you're like me,
you probably didn't see the difference.
I'll even show them to
you again, although ...
Alright, here was the first figure.
Here is the second figure.
Now, perhaps, some of you
spotted the difference there.
Now, supposing you didn't,
then, there's a certain
fact you didn't see.
The fact that those two
arrays were different.
Next question.
Did you see the object?
And here, I just have,
I call the object Sam.
Sam was in the second array,
it wasn't in the first.
Now, question,
I know you didn't see the difference,
but that's not the question,
I'm not interested in what facts you saw,
I'm interested in what objects you saw.
Did you see Sam the second time?
The fact that you didn't see that
Sam was a newer object in
the array is irrelevant.
One should not conclude from the fact
that you didn't see
that there was a difference
'cause the conclusion that
you didn't see the object
that made the difference.
Now, I'm going to argue
that your conscious experience,
when viewing the second array,
was different than it was the first time.
It had a richer texture.
It, in fact,
had a representation of Sam,
even if you didn't realize that it did,
even if you didn't
notice, could not detect,
that your conscious
experience was different,
it was different, even
though you weren't capable
of noticing or detecting the difference.
One point about the texture
of your conscious experience,
the facts you see don't
contribute in any way
to the texture of your experience.
Amy and Arnie see the
same object (a sunflower),
or a bunch of sunflowers,
and the flowers look the
same to both of them.
They see the same properties,
yet Amy sees that it is a sunflower,
she sees this fact,
that it is a sunflower,
and Arnie, ignorant of such things,
does not see that fact.
Yet, their conscious
experience is the same
even though the facts they
see are quite different.
What this illustrates
is that it's the objects
and properties you see
that constitute the texture
of your conscious experience.
The facts you see are irrelevant,
and I think most people, intuitives,
that fact perception is,
starts
after
you see objects and properties,
and then, the mind does something
with its visual experience,
and manufactures knowledge out of it,
but it, whether it manufactures
that knowledge or not
doesn't, itself, necessarily
change the experience
which that knowledge
comes out of.
Often, of course, the texture
of your conscious experience
is made different because
you see more objects
the second time, than
you do the first time,
but sometimes you can
see the same objects,
and a different texture is there
because of properties of those objects.
Here are nine squares or boxes,
supposing these boxes are piled up,
you see all nine boxes,
and then, you see the same nine boxes,
they're all painted blue,
and they're bunched together so closely,
you can't even see their edges.
Now,
I'm going to claim you
see all nine boxes here.
Of course, you can't see their edges.
You see this box, although,
you don't see its edges.
If someone wants to argue,
and perhaps, someone
will, someone always does,
argue that you don't see
the nine boxes there,
I'm going to ask which box don't you see.
If you say, "I don't see this one,"
I'm wondering what your
visual experience is like
if you can't see this box,
do you see what's behind that box?
I don't think you do,
I think that box is
occluding whatever's behind
and if it occludes what's
behind it, you must see it.
Well, this, then raises the question
which I think is the important
question for my purposes,
this is a question that's
bothered me for a long time now
because what I've given you so far
is a view of object perception
and property perception,
which makes what you
know, what you detect,
what you notice,
irrelevant to what you see,
even if you don't detect it,
even if you don't notice it,
even if you don't know that
you're seeing different things,
even if you don't see the difference,
the fact that there is a difference,
you still might see
the objects and properties
that make the difference,
you just don't realize you do.
Well, if that's the conclusion
of the first part of this talk,
then the question arises,
and I've been asked this
question often enough,
"Well, Fred, what then
makes your perception
"of something conscious, if
you don't even have to realize
"that you're conscious of
something to be conscious of it?
"What kind of test can we use
"for our conscious perception of an object
"if the person who's doing the perceiving,
"doesn't even have to know
"that they're conscious of something?"
There used to be a problem of other minds.
How do we know other bodies
are inhabited by minds?
This looks like it's
starting to produce a problem
of one's own mind, that is,
how does one find out about
one's own conscious experience,
then, what, that one is, in
fact, conscious of things
if one doesn't have to
notice them or detect them
to be conscious of them?
That's a serious question.
It's a serious question
if you want to do a
science of consciousness,
of conscious experience,
because without some kind of test,
without some way of telling,
that a person is conscious of something,
it looks like this question
of whether they're conscious of it just
doesn't get any traction at all,
sounds like a philosopher's question,
not a question that scientists
can legitimately raise.
Alright, so that's the
question that I'm now going to address,
and I'm going to propose to you a test.
Alright, this is a test
for seeing objects.
I'm going to suggest a
simple minded test here.
I mean, it's based on this idea
why is your experience of me conscious?
Because it gives you knowledge of me.
You know I've got a blue jacket on,
I'm waving my hands around,
I'm standing up behind,
there's all kinds of things
you know about me right now,
and the reason you know them about me
is because you can see me,
you're conscious of me,
and of various properties of me,
giving you knowledge,
so the proposed test is
that you're conscious of an object,
if for appropriate values
of the property symbol, F,
a person directly sees, and
therefore, knows the fact
that X is F.
Your experience of an object is conscious
if it gives you knowledge of that object.
This is the test.
I'm going to try to explain some of those
key words a little more
detailed in a moment,
but that, I wanted to give
you the capsule statement
of the view anyway.
So, consciousness of an object,
if gives you conscious
knowledge of that object.
This isn't circular
because I'm defining
consciousness of objects
in terms of conscious knowledge
of facts about that object.
So, the idea was this,
when you, I'm now going through that
little toy example of change blindness.
Here was the first, here was the second.
Now,
I'm claiming
you knew something about Sam
when you saw that second figure,
what did you know about Sam?
Well, that it is the same
color as the other ones.
He was blue.
He wasn't red.
You knew that, in fact, not only of Sam,
but you knew that of all
the objects in that array,
that none of them were red.
This is what it would look
like if Sam had been red.
You would've spotted it immediately,
and you know Sam wasn't red.
You know and knew when you saw it,
that none of them were red.
In fact, you knew also,
that none of them were star-shaped.
You knew something about
each and every object
in that array,
that it wasn't red, and
that it wasn't star-shaped,
if you knew something about
each and every object in that array,
then, you must have seen each
and every object in that array
according to this test for awareness.
Now, this test for awareness is not
just an informational test
that you're aware of something,
conscious of something
if you get information,
usable information about it,
because the blindsighters don't know
about the objects they perceive
without being conscious of them.
They get the right answers
when they're forced to choose,
but they take themselves to be guessing.
With you, there was no
guessing about that.
You knew, I suggest, when you
saw those array of objects,
that none of them were red.
There's some piece of knowledge
about each and every object
in that 30-element array.
There was no guessing about it.
Now, let me explain a bit about that test.
You have to be careful
in applying this test,
and here, I'm making some
philosophical moves.
I know you
you can know something about
an object without seeing it,
I gave you already examples.
I know things about my gas
tank without ever seeing it.
I know things about where George
Bush is without seeing him.
I read the newspapers,
so I know things, where
our President is, he's
back in Texas or something.
Often, of course, we
know things about objects
without seeing them.
So, when applying this test, I mean
you have the information from the object,
it has to be direct, not
delivered via some intermediary,
like an instrument, or a
message, or a photograph,
or a television image of something.
So, the information you get
from an object has to be direct.
Like, I can get information about you
without ever seeing you.
I look into an empty room and
I know you're not in there.
So, I know something about you
that you're not in this room,
'cause, I look in the room, it's empty.
Does that mean, according to this test,
that I see you?
Because I now know something about you
by looking in the room?
No, because
I know something about you
not by the way you look,
but by the way the room looks.
The information is not delivered directly.
Alright, one more example
to illustrate the way this
test is supposed to be applied.
Fito has fleas and I'm
told that he has fleas.
I can't see any of the fleas,
but I'm, let's say,
know, that he has fleas.
Now, I look at Fito,
and I can see that none
of the fleas on Fito
are as big as a basketball.
I just looked, somebody says,
"How big are those fleas?"
I said, "Well, I don't
know how big they are,
"but I know none of them
are as big as a basketball."
I can just see that, if they
were as big as a basketball,
I could see the flea,
but I can't see the fleas.
So, I know they're not.
Now,
that's a misapplication of the test
because the size of something
effects its visibility.
If you make something bigger,
you make it easier to see.
Color and shape don't effect
an object's visibility,
that's why
I use examples only of color and shape.
If you change the color of something
you change its noticeability.
If you make
among those blue objects,
if you make one of them red,
you'll notice it right away,
it'll pop out, as they say,
but by changing the color of
something from blue to red,
you don't make it visible,
you just make it noticeable.
Likewise, if I look into a room of people,
and someone's naked in the
room, I notice them immediately,
but taking off their clothes
doesn't make them visible, it
just makes them noticeable.
You know, someone with clothes
on, in a nudist colony,
would be very noticeable, but once again,
changing, removing, or putting clothes on
doesn't change an object's visibility.
It just changes its noticeability,
so when you apply this test,
I'll ask you to keep that in mind,
that I'm only gonna deal with properties
that you can know something has
that don't affect the thing's visibility,
just noticeability.
Alright, one more last
comment before I come to
the example that I'm really after here,
and that's about the kind of knowledge
that I'm talking about.
I'm claiming you knew
something about each and every
element in that multi-element array.
Now, this is a funny, perhaps,
use of the word, knowledge,
but let me give you an illustration
of the kind of knowledge I have in mind.
I was out to dinner with
a person the other night,
and
a perfectly ordinary
dinner, and the next day,
had someone ask me, they didn't,
but supposing someone
the next day asked me,
"Well, did your friend have
a hat on during dinner?"
I'd say, "No."
"How do you know?"
"Well, I sat right across from the table.
"I could see that he
didn't have a hat on,"
and they said, "Did you think
about that at the moment?
"Did you think to yourself,
'Gee, he doesn't have a hat on.'"
I said, "No, at the time
I didn't think that,
"but now that you raised
the issue, I know he didn't,
"and I didn't just learn he didn't.
"I knew since last night he didn't
"because I saw him,
"I could see that he
didn't have a hat on."
See, the idea here is, I knew
something about my friend
that he didn't have a hat on last night,
even though the first time
I even thought about that
was when my friend raised the question.
Then, I said, "Oh, yes,
he didn't have a hat on."
That's how I know that
when I got up this morning
there weren't any giraffes in my bedroom.
You know, if someone,
I didn't think about giraffes
this morning when I got up.
I didn't think that at all,
but if someone asked me
were there any in your
bedroom this morning?
I'd say, "No."
"How do you know, Fred?"
"Well, I can remember what my
room looked like this morning.
"There just weren't any giraffes in it.
"I didn't just learn
there weren't any giraffes
"when you asked me."
Now, what this suggests
is you don't have to kind of actively
think something to know it.
The knowledge you get, I'm
gonna call this tacit knowledge,
if you will, there's a great
many things you know tacitly,
not because when you
acquired the knowledge,
you're actually thinking
about it or believing it,
but because you've had the
kind of experience of it,
which, if you do later think about it,
will tell you what you need to know.
So, that's how I know my friend last night
was not wearing a hat at
dinner the other night
because when I'm asked about it,
I can recall what he looked like
and I know he didn't have a hat on,
and that's why I know and
knew since this morning
that there were no giraffes in my bedroom.
Alright, that's the kind of knowledge
I'm attributing to you about
that multi-element array.
When you saw that array, you
didn't think to yourself,
"Gee, none of those elements are red.
"None of them are star-shaped."
Nonetheless, once I remove the array
and asked you were any of them red,
were any of them star-shaped?
You could tell me, authoritatively,
on the basis of what you saw,
that none of them were.
You had that knowledge,
call it tacit knowledge,
but it was knowledge.
Alright, I'm going, whoops, I'm gonna go,
what I'm going to show you now
is
a brick wall,
think of it as a brick wall,
of course, it's just a picture,
but it's going to have,
it's gonna be very complex
that it's gonna have at
least 350 elements in it,
350 bricks.
I'm gonna show it to you
for a couple seconds,
then I'm gonna show it to you again,
and it's gonna be different,
and I don't know some of
you may see the difference,
but nobody I've ever shown this to
has ever seen the difference.
So, test yourself.
Did you see the difference?
Alright, now the question here is
not whether you saw the difference,
because seeing the
difference is seeing the fact
that those images were different,
and I'm assuming none
of you saw that fact,
but I'm not now interested
in what facts you saw,
I'm interested in what bricks you saw
'cause what I wanna know
is whether the ones in your
head are conscious experience
of all those bricks,
whether your conscious experience
is as rich and textured
as is, the image on this screen,
and I want to argue that it was.
Alright, how do I argue that it was?
By suggesting that you know something
about each and every brick in that wall.
What do you know about each
and every brick in the wall?
Well
you know
that this is the, this is
the added brick, by the way.
We call that brick, Sam.
That's a brick that was
there the second time,
it wasn't there the first time.
Now, I think you know
something about or when you saw
the second figure, you
knew something about Sam,
and in fact, you knew something
about every brick in that wall.
What did you know?
Well, you've already, I've given away
the kind of thing I'm
gonna claim you knew.
You knew, for instance,
that none of them were blue.
This is what the wall would've looked like
had Sam been blue,
and you would've spotted Sam immediately,
if Sam had been blue.
So, you know Sam wasn't blue.
In fact, you know they were all orange.
You know that none of them were blue,
and you know, in fact, that
none of them were tilted.
They were all horizontal.
You would've spotted a tilted one.
So, this is what you knew when
you saw the second figure,
that each and every brick
in that wall was orange.
I'm not using orange very strictly here,
just think of orange as
not blue, or black, or
all the other colors it might have been.
Let's just say
that it wasn't blue
and it was horizontal, that
it wasn't tilted like this.
Those are things you knew
about the bricks, each brick.
Now, I've got to argue here
that not only did you know that about Sam,
but you knew it about each
and every brick in that wall,
and the argument's going to
be fairly straightforward.
I'm going to claim that you had 350
distinct pieces of knowledge,
one for each brick in the wall.
Now,
you didn't have one piece of knowledge
of something general in nature,
you didn't know that none
of the bricks in the wall
were blue or tilted.
You didn't have that
piece of general knowledge
because you couldn't see
whether those were all
the bricks in the wall.
For all you know,
I gave you a snapshot
of one part of the wall
and maybe there were other
parts that you couldn't see
in which, there were
blue and tilted bricks.
So, you couldn't see that
none of the bricks in the wall
were blue or titled
because you couldn't see
that you were seeing all of the bricks.
Nonetheless, if those were
all the bricks in the wall
and I assure you they were,
then you could see of each
and every one of them,
that none of them were blue or tilted,
as I indicate,
and logicians express this,
this is kinda the array
knowledge versus the de dicto
that for all x, if x
is a brick in the wall,
you could see that x is
neither blue nor tilted.
That's what you could see.
Something about each and
every brick in the wall.
You do not see
that for all x, if x
is a brick in the wall,
well then, it's neither blue nor tilted,
you don't, you can't see something
general in nature like that,
but you do know something
about each and every brick,
but it's a distributed sense of all,
not a collective sense of all.
Alright, conclusion.
Therefore, those of you
of normal vision, now, this
is not a priori philosophy.
I don't know.
I'm making a claim about
everyone in this room
that you all knew something
about each and every brick in the wall.
I don't know whether that's true or not
because I don't know that much
about your individual visual capacities,
maybe some of you are colorblind,
maybe some of you could
barely see this screen,
let alone see each brick up there.
Maybe some of you looked with only one eye
and looked so briefly
that some of the bricks
fell on your blindspot.
You didn't actually
see some of the bricks.
All kinds of things
could've prevent individuals
from seeing what I'm claiming
people of normal vision would
have seen if they looked.
So, this is a, an
empirical claim I'm making,
that if you had normal vision,
and if you let, looked
for several seconds,
several seconds, by the way,
is enough time for the eye
to execute six or seven saccades
making different parts of that brick wall
fall on the sensitive part
of the retina, the fovea.
So, if you looked at that brick wall for
just two or three seconds,
chances are, the eye
executed enough saccades
to make most of the bricks anyway
fall on that very sensitive discriminating
part of the retina,
but this is an empirical claim I'm making,
if, it would have to be tested.
What I would do is show
you those brick walls,
take each individual one by one,
show you them again and again
and see if you could tell,
whether any brick was blue or tilted
in a two-second exposure.
My bet is that people of vision
will be able to tell
and then, know whether
any brick in that wall
is blue or tilted in two-second exposures,
no matter which brick we're talking about.
If that's true of you,
and whether it's true of you or not,
it's an empirical question,
then, I'm going to
claim you know something
and could see that something was true
of each and every brick
in the wall, hence,
according to the proposed test
for consciousness of an object,
you were conscious of
every brick in the wall,
350 different bricks,
and that tells us something
important about the texture,
the richness of your conscious experience
of a complex stimulus, like a brick wall,
and I think it tells us something about
our everyday experiences
of the complex stimuli
we look at everyday.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauding)
- That was wonderful.
I want to ask you,
I don't know what you would say
to the following proposition,
but you can sometimes see
global facts about an array,
good in front of you,
without dividing that from your seeing
of lots of local facts about the array.
What I mean is,
for example, if you took
your geometric display
for change blindness and you asked us
"Is this symmetrical?"
You know, "Is there an axis
about which this is symmetric?"
Then, one way to do it
would be to see where each and
everything in the display is
then write all that down,
and then, derive from that by
some geometric calculation,
whether the thing is symmetric,
but actually, that's not what we do.
You just look and have a glance,
you can see this global fact,
the display is symmetric.
So, let me just ask you,
how do you feel about that?
Seeing a global fact, instead of an array.
- That sounds exactly right,
the way you described that.
In this case, you're
seeing a fact about the,
the set or the array, not
a fact about any individual
in the array, yup.
- [Participant] And what I wonder is,
isn't everything in the
array being the same color,
like that, a global property of the array?
You just look at it
and you say, "Yeah, it's
all the same color,"
but I didn't derive that
from a lot of local facts
about the color of this,
and the color of that,
and the color of that.
- Alright, yeah.
Well, if you didn't derive it,
see, let me,
well, the brick wall,
if I put a piece of masking
tape over any brick,
I would destroy your knowledge
that none of the bricks
were blue or tilted.
You could no longer tell,
you would no longer be a reliable teller,
whether none of the
bricks were blue or tilted
because I had obscured
an individual brick.
I conclude from that,
oh, I guess we're, I conclude from that
that it was, in part, at least
the way that brick looked,
that told you what you now
know about all the bricks,
that none of them were blue or tilted,
and if I obscure any brick in that wall,
it's going to destroy the
knowledge, which you have,
I take it that means that
each brick, looking some way to you,
was instrumental in what you came to know.
- [Participant] Okay, I see the move,
but I wouldn't go in indefinitely,
but I see the move,
but I guess what I wonder is,
if that is the right quantifier,
in all the bricks in the wall,
and what I see at a glace is
that all the visible bricks
are the same color,
and if you occlude one,
that's fine it doesn't count anymore.
It's no longer a visible brick,
but what I'm still getting at a glance
is this global property
of the whole array.
All the visible bricks are the same color.
I mean, (chuckles) forgetting
global properties of an array,
vision is just gonna tell
you about what's visible.
You know, it will do its best,
and if you go around to occluding things,
well its just by itself.
- Yeah, I guess
this is good.
I think what I have to
argue here, I won't,
is that this is not a
global fact about the array.
You're, when you say
you're able to tell
something about the array
that none of them, none
of the visible ones,
that seems to me a distributive claim
about each and every brick.
It's not a fact about,
well, it adds up to a fact
about all the visible ones,
but the general fact
that you reach comes from
what you know about each
and every brick, but
nice question.
- If you allow yourself to talk
in such an unrestricted way
about seeing facts, it looks
like you're committed to saying
that we see an infinite number of facts
because if you can see
that there are no giraffes
in your bedroom,
well presumably, you also
saw there were no elephants,
no aardvarks, no hippopotamidae,
no Chevrolet station wagons, et cetera,
and you saw that there
weren't three giraffes,
there weren't four giraffes, et cetera.
So, it looks like you've
got an infinite number.
That's an enormous visual capacity.
And then, my second question is
one feels uncomfortable
with your handling of the
of the change blindness cases
because it looks like there's
some slight of hand involved,
and I wonder how you
would deal with cases like
the change blindness experiment
where they throw the basketball
and then, the guy walks through wearing a
an orangutan costume.
Are you committed to the
viewer that you do see the guy,
even though you were not aware of it?
- Yeah.
- And how do you deal,
what's the knowledge you get?
- Well the, he
he wasn't wearing a
clown suit or you know,
I don't know.
I would have to find something
you knew about the gorilla.
Alright this, John's eluding to the
kind of change blindness experiment where
subjects are asked to watch
people throwing basketballs
and concentrate on how
many passes this team made,
and while they're doing this,
somebody dressed in a gorilla costume
walks through the scene and
exits and people have said,
"Did you notice anything funny going on?"
Often people, often than
not, there are people saying
"No, I didn't see anything, what's funny?"
I was with the group that, the
girl, woman next to me said,
she's with, we all knew
when we were watching for the gorilla,
so, but she said she
didn't see the gorilla.
Now, John's asking me
am I going to claim she
did see the gorilla,
just didn't notice him.
I think it's likely she did see him
and didn't notice him.
It's like my wife at the farmer's market.
I did see her, I just didn't notice her.
I thought she was wearing a red sweater,
so I didn't pay any attention
to the blue sweaters and
so on, yep, I did see her.
I think this person was
concentrating on the passes,
just didn't notice that gorilla.
How I would argue it,
given the thesis here,
I would have to show
that there's something
the person knew about the gorilla
that, that could be demonstrated
and I don't know what that could be.
I'd have to think up something,
but your first question was, yeah.
- [Participant] It relates
to the first question.
Namely, it looks like it's going to be
some negative thing that you know,
like, she wasn't
as big as a Cadillac station wagon,
'cause if she had been,
then you would have noticed
- Yeah.
- [Participant] The gorilla,
but then it, then it looks like,
well now, if we allow ourselves to talk
in an unrestricted way
about seeing negative facts,
it looks like you see an
infinite number of negative facts
whenever you open your eyes.
- Yeah, I,
but I'm not worried
about all this knowledge
since it all comes free, kind of,
that is, given that you
don't have to believe it,
no active belief
because that's the sense, in
which, the guy I was having
dinner with last night, I
knew he wasn't wearing a hat.
Well, I knew he wasn't naked,
I knew he wasn't in a clown costume, and
all these infinite things,
but they all come free
because the information, which
supports the knowledge claim
was all there in the experience
and that's what tacit knowledge is,
knowing things, which is
supported by the experience,
in this case, the remembered experience,
you gotta remember the experience enough.
If you forget what he looked like,
and somebody says, "Was he wearing a hat?"
And you said, "I don't think so,
"but I actually don't remember.
"I wasn't paying that
much attention to him."
But, if you were paying
attention, then you know,
and that's a free piece of knowledge
and if it's free, that free,
infinite doesn't matter.
You get it all.
(audience applauding)
(bright music)